to other world news now and to sudan
where thousands are on the streets again
to protest against the military takeover
internet services are reported to have
been suspended there the reinstated
prime minister has been trying to
appoint a new cabinet for more than a
month without success the protesters
want the military to stay
from a transitional to a democracy
muhammad val has been covering this
story from khartoum muhammad what are
the numbers like so far how many people
have started together
well there is no precise estimation but
it's very clear that
the there are huge numbers that have
been gathering in the three three parts
of the of the sudanese capital that's uh
khartoum bahri and khartoum itself the
capital and um doorman we said before
that all the bridges have been
blocked by the security forces and the
the presence of these security forces
this time around is has increased almost
300 percent compared to last week or the
the the previous demonstrations
right now access is still blocked
for those who want to access khartoum
from um or from cartoon bahrain but what
we have noticed during the last half
hour or so is that huge numbers have
been able to push from the south of the
capital cartoon itself the central
cartoon towards the presidential palace
and we've been told that they are there
they are now about 100
a few hundred meters away from the uh
from the presidential palace that's very
dangerous we have seen that happening
last time
suddenly bridges were open
everybody is still asking questions
about what happened and how it happened
last time but now we have this huge push
from within the capsule the central
capital cartoon itself apparently some
of the protesters were able to move
probably yesterday or overnight to this
area because they know the bridges will
be closed so they moved into the central
area of khartoum to the south and they
are pushing towards the presidential
palace about one kilometer away from it
as i speak
we only have about two minutes left of
this bulletin muhammad but just quickly
tell us about the mood of the protesters
there seems to be relatively peaceful
scenes from what we're seeing live from
khartoum
well that's usually the case until they
get attacked by the security forces we
have seen a pattern in sudan protesters
usually don't resort to violence on
their own and that what they do is a
kind of reaction when they are attacked
by security forces and the the the way
they do that is they they burn tires and
they sometimes throw rocks at policemen
in reaction but until they are
until they are blocked their passage is
blocked they remain
calm and they continue to march towards
the destination where they are supposed
to make a sit-in if they want to do a
sitting
a sitting or they just want to deliver a
message to the authorities
so far that's that's the case they are
marching peacefully
and slowly towards the presidential
palace
and we are expecting no doubt about it
that they will be met with violence well
we appreciate that update and we'll
speak to you at the top of the hour with
more developments no doubt thank you
very much muhammad val live for us in
cartoon